this is greens we're talking about we're
talking about dreams
so many people were asking me like how
how do I live my dream Gary and you know
I don't have time I'd mortgages and
bills and responsibilities in my job I
don't have time for my side house with
my twitch channel my Instagram account
my Shopify store selling pretties and I
keep getting to this new place which is
talk to me about your bills like why'd
you buy an apartment that stretches you
why is your car so fancy like why do you
need the new Gucci every time like why
are you why are you going out Thursday
Friday and Saturday night like why are
you going to Coachella like why why are
you going to a vendors opening night and
buying the biggest piece of popcorn and
candy like the answer to all of your
questions is not how much money you make
or how much time you have it's what
you're spending your money huh why do
you want the newest pair of Yeezys why
why
[Music]
you're not entitled to Angelina you're
not in tight nobody's entitled to be of
amazing dancer nobody that tours the
world and gets to dance and open for
Beyonce and make 580 a year and [ __ ]
live it and go to [ __ ] you know in
Monaco on the [ __ ] weekends like it's
not that works everybody starts at zero
some people start at different places
but anybody who does it for themselves
sacrifice like yes like roof like my
city's expensive move like my car
payments are high sell your car and buy
a piece-of-shit car take the bus
this is the rules we're talking about
we're talking about dreams
[Music]
we're talking about like I want to be a
professional gamer we're talking about I
want to get paid $200,000 to give a
speech we're talking about [ __ ] that
isn't normal
[Music]
Jews require sacrifices people don't
want to sacrifice like some reason DNA
parenting circumstance I'm on the
extreme end of everything's my fault
nobody owes me [ __ ] I shouldn't get
anything unless I bleed for it
[Music]
it's one big framework dirac of like of
self-esteem lack of self-esteem /
insecurity entitlement or accountability
it's these huge things
[Music]
I'm not judging with people other than
I'm asking people and I'm bringing up a
different debate that isn't being talked
about a lot which is why do you want to
go to Coachella that's what I'm
interested in
[Music]
[Music]
you